hello everyone welcome back to another
tutorial on C++ I think we're up to
video 13 and this time we're going to
talk about arrays I'm gonna I I was
gonna do data all as one video but that
would be too large so I'm gonna break it
up a little bit I'm gonna talk about
arrays this time and then and then
vectors and then probably lists and then
maps and I think that'll be enough
because they all kind of have their
nuances and they have different use
cases so what we're gonna do first of
all we're just gonna make a new
directory and I'm gonna call it data
toots I guess yeah and there we go we'll
change directory into it actually you
know what we'll just open this directory
with Visual Studio code and you'll see
there's nothing in it right now get rid
of this welcome thing I guess I could
have clicked new file there on the
Welcome menu but I'm just going to do
that right here right click and data
toots Oh or there's other ways of making
new files I want to change directory
into this folder anyway the reason I'm
doing all this is just because as a new
coder you want to get used to
messing with files and and doing it from
the command line or from your editor so
just just something you should probably
get really used to so I change directory
into to this data toots folder and I
could make a new file here or I could
just do the touch thing that I like to
do
there's people seem to there's a lot of
different ways of doing this people seem
to have their own way of doing a lot of
people like to echo to do files and
write something into it but I like to do
just touch because it makes a blank file
so we're going to touch a new main dot
cpp in there it appears we're also gonna
go ahead and and touch a make file and
there we go and in our make file first
of all we'll just make a default one
that just compiles our main dot cpp that
way we can just run a plain old make and
it'll he'll compile and if we update our
compile command later we can just update
this make file so the here's our main
we're going to start out with to
conclude iostream because that's how
we're going to
our data we're gonna have a main and at
the very end we're gonna return zero and
here's gonna be our meat and potatoes
but I won't talk about a raise now what
a raise are let me preface this with a
little a little bit of a scenario say
you want to keep a you want to keep five
different variables of the same type
they're in order and you might do
something like this I don't know we'll
say date one and a bunch of them and
then data to data three day to four day
to five and this could be anything
depending on your program maybe it's
something like maybe you got five
different attacks so it's something like
this it could be could be anything
that's in an order so rather than
keeping all of these separate what you
can do is you can just put them all as
one and you can say okay it's an INT of
attacks and then you put these brackets
on the end and end it like that but this
is underlined with squigglies because
this brackets means it's an array and
c++ needs to know how many are in this
array that we can allocate memory so you
have five attacks we put five in there
and now it's happy and what this is it
is five integers that are all lined up
and the and the great thing about them
being perfectly aligned in memory is you
can scan through them really fast I'm
going to change this back to data cuz it
just makes more sense to me so this can
hold up to five pieces of data and
they're all lined up as we went over I
think in the second tutorial on some
stuff about variables the size of an
integer is one byte so this will tobe a
total of five bytes and they'll be nice
and just lined up in memory so if we
ever want to flip through them it's
gonna be super fast but they all start
out without anything
or depending on your compiler just might
be dummy data so we'd want to initialize
them and this number of five or how many
it starts out with can't change with
arrays and that's sort of the drawback
of them but we'll get into that a little
later the drawback is once you set a
size to them it can't be changed unless
you just completely start over and
delete it make a whole new one which
sometimes people do and there's ways of
doing that through functions and
returning it and stuff like that that's
a little more complicated so I'm not
going to talk too much about that but so
what you want to do is you want to loop
through this and then basically just to
sign them all so we'll start with that
we'll just do a for loop and why is less
than 5 and then 5 plus plus of course
and we'll say data at the 8th spot
equals zero so we'll just set them all
to 0 so as we run this program it will
first allocate the 5 bytes for these 5
pieces of data then we'll hit this loop
you'll go through 5 times and if you're
questioning the 0 thing well these start
at 0 so this isn't 1 through 5 it's 0
through 4 so that's important to know
oh by the way as I've been doing before
tutorial c++ tutorial 13 arrays that's
where we're at so this isn't this is 0 1
2 3 4 so that's why the for loop looks
like this it starts at 0 so we assign
data at 0 location and this is this is
how later when you're calling it you
tell it which one to access so first
this will access 0 sign that to 0
and it'll flip to the next state Oh plus
plus once and b1 so then it'll sign data
one at location one to zero and data at
location two to zero data location three
to zero and so on until it's and it
continues while I is less than five so
when I is five that would be off the
array and we don't want to do that and
that's why it's a less than if we were
less than equal to this program would
crash but since it's less than it only
goes to four it goes right to the end of
the memory and then stops doesn't go any
further so if I show you this you would
see that it works now I'm just gonna do
another one of these loops just to get a
little output going on and I'm just
going to just so we can see what's going
on here so I'll do a standard C out and
I'll say data at and I'll put an eye
here and then I'll just do that and
we'll put a new line at the end of this
and what rather than have it in that
same line I'm just gonna do this on a on
a new line itself no I I could put that
here it doesn't matter either way it's
fine there we go so now if I run this I
should I should get a data add in all
the eye locations and then and they
should all be 0 because it's assigned to
0 so let's go ahead and run that and
just confirm so we're gonna make a make
you know what actually I'm gonna do one
little more advanced thing real quick
just to help speed things up and I'm
gonna do I want to put in this make file
another command called run that does the
exact same thing but also on the next
line down I'm gonna put that it just
launches our program so anytime I put
make run it's gonna go directly to this
one it's just a quick recap on make
files if you type playing on make it
does the top one it doesn't matter what
it's named I could name it this and it
would run it but if you want to specify
exactly which one it runs
as you might have more let's let's do a
clear or clean and we're gonna do a yeah
we'll just do remove our a dot exe so
that's a common one to have two so now
if we type make run it's gonna compile
our program and it's going to run our
program and we can put over here to that
it only compiles if this was updated so
what's over here it checks the timestamp
on and holds the timestamp on if this
was updated since the last compile it'll
recompile if this hasn't been updated
since the last compile it will not run
what's under here now this is a special
case where we want to at least run this
anyway so and what would happen here is
if this didn't get updated it wouldn't
execute this so it wouldn't even run it
and we wanted to run run no matter what
so we're gonna leave that off here and
instead we're gonna do this we're gonna
say run our all which is make sure I'm
gonna see if I get this right I think
it's that and this tells it to run this
make file in the all command which would
go up here and that checks for the
dependency of the main and decides
whether and used to recompile it so it
will just go to the next line after it
handles that and that way this run will
compile no matter what let's see if I
got it right the first time I did
awesome so that's how you call another
command within your make file it's just
like that and then the commands name
like we could do something like this and
make it clean every time maybe you know
I liked just just to go a little further
with make files as they're super handy I
want to make one called
rebuild and this one is going to do a
let's see it it's gonna do the clean
command and then it's going to let's see
do we want to I think we just want to
compile no matter what on this one so
we'll do this so there we go a rebuild
we'll do a clean and then an all run and
we could do that too anytime we want to
just recompile there we go which will
just delete our executable our
executable is gonna get overwritten
anyway but just wanted to show you that
example so you can get fancy with these
and do all sorts of things and it
doesn't even have to be C++ stuff as you
get better with the command line stuff
you can put any command line stuff in
here and that's the real beauty of make
files they're not just for C++ but you
definitely have to know them for coding
this tutorial is not about make files we
already did those but it just seemed
relevant so there you go I hope that
helps you guys out a little more if you
were a little stuck on make files still
and let's continue here we got our data
hat I didn't run that a bit ago and it
did work and it is just showing all
zeroes so if we want to assign them to
the integer I that should go zero
through four so let's make let's do a
make run on that and there we go
works as expected they're all nice and
aligned in memory now one last thing I
want to show you or a couple last things
actually two last things and I think I'm
gonna call it I don't want this to go on
too long is there's two different ways
people usually deal with these arrays
like I just put the number in here and
you see how to type it in multiple
places too to handle going through there
right sighs so okay I guess three last
things I want to show you going off the
array so what happens if you go too far
and you go off the array well let's just
do it to recompile did it work
this should crash I think maybe my
compiler is being smart and not a not
messing up but if you go off the array
typically it'll crash for some reason
this is not I think it's because I have
a more modern compiler so you choose to
see - version 703 so it might be auto
correcting for that but I should be at
least getting a warning that's being
like whoa dude you're going off the
array because what this is doing is this
is probably writing to random parts of
memory that aren't even accessible
anymore which could mess up other stuff
on your computer so I'm honestly very
surprised that it's even allowing me to
do that I'm used to this sort of thing
crashing I think it's just because I'm
on a more modern compiler than what I
originally learn C++ on so what I'm
gonna do here is I'm gonna add a
compiler directive that is called wall
so it's - W also this is compiler
directive this is sort of a new thing I
haven't talked about before but when
you're compiling you can tell your
compiler to do certain things a certain
way and what this is it stands for
warning hall now that's deceptive
because the way it's called warning hall
it doesn't actually show you all the
warnings I know unintuitive right but
you'll find a lot of stuff like that
with programming they just happen to get
that name because it was the best name
they could think of at the time it's all
I can really figure that happened there
and if you're make files not working by
the way make sure this is a tab if you
put in four spaces it won't work it's
got to be a tab in some editors when you
press tab rather than actually tab over
they put in spaces so watch out for that
you go to your settings if that's
happening and just FYI that's pretty
important I know a million people who
have been stuck on that forever and been
like I don't understand what's happening
so it's just saying that again
okay so warning off now if I compile I'm
just gonna do run which we'll call this
one up here
it should tell me all the warnings and
there's none I'm I'm baffled by this
this going off the array should should
blatantly yell at me and give me all
sorts of warnings and I don't understand
why it's not so I'm just fool out
full-on baffled by that I don't know
let's try to let's try to spit out the
data from like all these locations now
this certainly be some messed up data
from random parts of memory so who knows
what its gonna say it should crash you
should do a core dump I don't understand
why it's not flat-out don't understand
there we go so looks like it is going
through WTF so that one's 45 that's
pretty awkward but what on earth is
happening so I actually need to look
this up this is a weird thing if I only
assigned it to be 5 bytes and I'm going
way over it it should not be functioning
properly it should be doing all sorts of
weird stuff so that's weird let me just
do a few more tests here okay there we
go
so apparently it just lets you keep on
assigning even with warning all doesn't
give you a warning about this blows my
mind okay but here's here's a great
example
I only assign the first 5 of them 0
through 4 so the rest are just random
data from my memory this negative huge
number is like the around the largest
negative integer you can get so and then
we got some 1 0 is 32 so these are just
bits of my memory that it's spitting out
that are who knows why because I didn't
assign them so I don't know why I yeah
I'm not gonna be able to explain that
I'm gonna have to do some research to
understand why but don't do this if you
only make this 5 in size and you go way
off of it your program should crash and
it will crash eventually because as you
saw even when we did assign it at one
time
why it kind of worked it for some reason
puts data at seven as 45 so it's it's
not gonna be consistent if you don't
make this consistent even if for some
reason it doesn't crash on you to begin
with which it should say there we go
when we made it 45 in size to it make it
45 bytes the 7-1 was okay so apparently
it's just force doing it anyway and just
not giving a not giving a crap about
what we do this actually blows my mind
that it's allowing this okay well I
don't have a clear explanation from that
but don't do it make sure you only go to
the size of your array so that was gonna
be point of that that was supposed to
show you a crash and explain that but
instead I learned that it's just gonna
let you do it but assign maybe random
ones wrong and so yeah keep it to the
right size so what people usually do is
they do a say a Const and well actually
rather than an end
let's do unsigned and because you can't
have it a negative size so you don't
need the sign unsigned int and we'll
call it I'm gonna do this in all caps
max size it's its traditional and
programming to do your Const as a all
capitalized and we'll say max size
equals 5 in that way I just copy we can
just replace all these files with max
size and we'll be sure we'll never go in
off the array and yeah so tell if I run
that what's it complaining about
oh it's complaining about this
comparison this integer here is being
compared to an unsigned integer and
since I have warning all on it has given
me a warning about the sign comparisons
with see a comparison between a signed
and an unsigned integer so that could
cause some weird problem so it gives you
a warning which is probably way less
important
than this so I mind-blown
but yeah so so that's that and since it
can never be negative we could just make
these all unsigned integers and that
would be fine and that would take care
of our warning there other optionally we
could just make this an integer but
since this can't be negative like I said
we might as well make it unsigned that
way we can at least go higher because
the max unsigned int is higher than the
max on an int because int is int and
unsigned int are the same size of both
one byte but unsigned int only it
handles all the the pluses so it has one
more bit to work with and essentially
allows it to be twice as high as the max
int okay well last thing say say you
don't have this max size thing and
you're just you're being fed some data
you don't know what size it is say it's
happens to be that size and so you need
to loop through it but you don't know
what size to loop through say that so
this is totally unknown you don't you
don't know what this number is another
trick to doing this is well you start
your I as zero as before but you say
while I is less than okay so how do you
get this number
that's that's what I'm going to show you
how you get the size of this so you can
loop through it there's no traditional
way and that's kind of one of the
drawbacks of arrays but you can make it
not so much of a drawback because you
can get this number by doing a size of
operation now if you remember from one
of the first tutorials the size of and
if you do any data type you do the size
of this you'll get the size of it and
since it's an integer
it'll just be how many are in it because
it's one byte per and this tells you how
many more bytes so I'll do that size of
data and bytes I'll just make that
explicit there and it'll show you
and I'll go a little further with this
just to cover all my bases and here we
go oh it doesn't understand max sighs
let's comment these out for the moment
and here we go we get the size of data
in bytes it's two hundred and twenty
four six six zero that's a little larger
than we expected so what is going on
there well what do you size of divided
by the size of an integer am I saying
this wrong oh I am I am so all that I
said earlier about an integer being one
byte is wrong as you're gonna see in a
sec sorry because the size of an integer
is 4 bytes and the size of an unsigned
they're all four bytes not one a
characters one so that was my mistake
and there we go it gives us a since we
have that warning all it says unused
variable and that's because we're not
using this anywhere in our code so it
does give you warnings about that we
have a warning call which can't be handy
because you can get rid of stuff stuff
that's not used and a size of an ant is
four bytes so that number we were seeing
earlier that's four times this number
okay and the point of me showing you all
this here is you can get the size of
this by taking the size of the entire
thing
and then dividing it by the size of
whatever the data type is so size of
this entire thing divided by the side as
the data's will give you the size of
this array so we should get this same
number now so let me go ahead and do a
make run and yeah we got the right
number and what you can do with that
is you can loop through with that number
you can just take this right here put it
in as the max size there so while it's
less than that and you go ahead and just
loop through it and now we're gonna get
a thing that goes on for a long time
there we go so loop through all of them
and we didn't need to store this number
because we just grabbed the size of it
so that's another way of handling
looping through those and if being
whatever size and you don't have to
change your for loops or not have to
hold a constant but the disadvantages is
you have to do this a little bit of math
here on every loop so that can slow down
your program so it might be a little
better to do something like let's see
well I guess we could make it constant
and size of data call here and then get
this that way we only do this size
calculation once and we can grab this
size of data and pop it in there pop it
in there which if you're doing C++ you
should care about speed this could save
you a little bit of time and your
programs run time it's gonna be so
minuscule that no one's ever gonna
notice really but that way at least
doesn't have to do the same calculation
a million times just saves it once
stores in size of data so there you go I
think that's all I'm gonna say about a
race for now I hope to help you
understand them and the potential
pitfalls of them ways to use them
different options for looping through
them and kind of the point to them so
advantage they are the fastest data
storage just because they're aligned in
memory disadvantage
apparently the compiler lets you run
over them and doesn't always crash when
it should but it will probably at some
point and looping through them you don't
necessarily know the size but there are
ways around that so so there you go
alright thanks for watching this
tutorial I will see you in the next one
keep on coding guys and keep it real
don't forget this give this video a
thumbs up leave a comment if you have
any questions or any insights or maybe
something I missed that does help
support this channel just interacting in
any way so I would greatly appreciate
that and
keep it real peace out